you sure he wants to do this interview
with you I don't know if he really like
negotiations apparently and they are
very fragile you're a risk you're
putting them at risk by simmer you ever
want me just to lay the smackdown on him
I will do it free of charge anyway no
but I'll do it extra for coach for
myself oh yes that was Mike Zimmer the
Vikings head coach with us at the league
meetings hey Zimmer and I are fine now
yeah everything is good whatever was
there is no longer there until I keep
talking about it so much that it is
there again all over again we were there
and now is the time we usually do it on
Wednesday but now it's the time we get
to air our grievances for the week and I
will let you go first as long as we
don't hear about your hotel room with
the sink where the bed is
other than that feel free to grieve away
hey you know you're at a good hotel when
you can roll over in bed and almost wash
your hands at the same time that's when
you know you go Dan this place is
special okay all right all right
I might my earring agree didn't have
that feature in my room Yeah right
exactly
I'm gonna I'm gonna jump off a little
bit right where we left off there with
Mike Zimmer I had a few I had two
coaches okay I'm not gonna name names
anything like that but we're a little
disappointed about a negative thing I
might have said during the season or
evaluating them or whatever it may be
and they wanted to make sure I knew
about it when we were at the owners
meetings okay and you know what that's
fine I have no problem with that I
understand sometimes I may sing
sometimes I'm wrong I admit that but my
grievance is you know I just don't want
to hear about it because you know if
you're not gonna call me and thank me or
do something like that or say hey you
know you know I watched you a hundred
other times and you said really nice
things about me and I appreciate it a ba
ba ba then I just don't want to hear
about you know all I said one bad thing
about you and that's all I paid
attention to I hate that crap because I
had two coaches like I told you that
came up to me and voiced some
displeasure and not that I don't you
know I understand it I appreciate them
coming up to me face-to-face and saying
that but at the same time
you know hey come on sensitivity card -
okay that's out there let's please I
mean you know in these two cases I
argued back yeah but you know you you
have you do you must not watch but what
about the other hundred things I say
positive about you I never get any
feedback for that like hey thanks for
sticking up for me or a good point or
you know everybody's on me but you stuck
up for me none of that so that's my
first grievance don't want to hear it
from any of the coaches anymore shut up
Chris but don't you realize this is how
it goes yeah they never pay any
attention to the praise I know
only pay attention to the criticism and
I I've had this issue with plenty of
people throughout the league and people
at the league office you know I'll run
into certain people from illega office
and they'll say oh you got to say
something something nice well you're not
paying attention to 99 nice things I say
you're only obsessing over the one thing
that you disagree with you don't like
the criticizes you so I agree with you
let me just share this right I had a
couple of experiences although not as
direct as yours that there was one
situation on that Monday night event
that they have out on the lawn where
everybody kind of mingles and gets along
and it's about I love that event there
was a and I'm not even going to specify
what position the person holds somebody
gave me the shoulder bone are you trying
to send me a message and if so you got
to come at me with a little bit more
than that buddy boy no not that that's a
hint as to who it was because we had
John Dorsey on the program it was great
he gets it he understands how the world
works and you're gonna get a certain
amount of criticism but you're gonna get
a certain amount of praise and you know
what you we're not doing our jobs if
we're not candid that there was not what
else happened I better be careful how I
phrased my words here but I I agree with
you that that is a real dynamic and and
let me just throw out an item of praise
here while we're generally without
naming names identifying folks who may
have have disrespected us Frank Reich
the Colts head coach came over to the
set yesterday to apologize for not being
able to make it on to the show
because we had him penciled in a couple
of times and it didn't work out and he
he wanted and that's the first time
that's ever happened in all the years
I've been doing this that somebody who
we tried to book and we understand we
can't you know there's a lot of moving
parts yeah they're coming in on enemies
of leaving meetings and maybe there's a
stack of people waiting to be
interviewed he came over to say I'm
sorry that we weren't able to make it
work and say you know this guy gets it
he gets it right and and also if we have
to criticize him at some point he's not
gonna get better than the shake-up I
understand this is the way it works yes
exactly right I mean they're grown men
we do it to everybody you're being paid
a lot of money and yes I mean we're
critical at times but at the same time
we do show praise and it's just part of
the job I know I had to go through it as
a quarterback in the NFL I certainly
would see people at my locker when the
media would come in and go dan ba ba ba
just told me you wrote some crappy
article about me but who cares what I
you know hey it's their job and more
times than not when they wrote something
crappy about me or something I did
playing wise it was true I played like
crap or I made a dumb decision so you
know you just cuz sometimes just got to
take it on the chest and realize you're
being paid a lot of money to play a
sport and it's part of the job is taking
that criticism and it's one of those
guys who criticized you when you played
I can confirm that that criticism did
indeed happen let me just share one more
thing though and I'm trying to say I
don't because look I I feel like the
whole experience is kind of off the
record and I don't want to call anyone
out but but there was an employee I'm
not gonna be any more specific than that
yeah of an organization of which I have
been critical in the recent past that I
saw yesterday and hello hello and then I
heard I heard a little I heard a little
something on the back end you know you
get that little mutter you know what I
mean yeah after you pass was on yeah
yeah there was a there was a little
mutter and if you're if you're watching
or listening out there individual I
pastor today I heard you and that's okay
I don't mind I don't mind but I I did
hear you okay message received oh you
sure you sure you're not just being
paranoid or something no no no I
I heard I heard something and there was
nobody else around so yeah I heard
something I liked here's my here's my
grievance and and this relates to the
competition committee generally with the
exception of Sean Payton who was the one
that seemed to understand which way the
wind was blowing or at least which way
it needed to blow there was a disconnect
between what the competition committee
was trying to do and what ownership
ultimately did and I think that you know
we a lot of times people like genuflect
at the order of the competition
committee that they are the influential
rulemaking body a lot of times they they
recommend something that gets ignored
that doesn't get past that that is not
an uncommon event and I think part of
the obligation of being on that
committee and specifically being the
chairperson as rich McKay is you have to
project you have to have foresight as to
how this is all going to play in the
room which means you better be working
the phone lines to talk to people
owners coaches etc to make sure that
what you guys are trying to do meshes
with what people are going to want when
it's time to have these meetings so we
don't have to make sausage in one day
because a lot of the concerns we raised
earlier about some of the nuances of
replay review for pass interference
these are things that could have been
discussed and planned for ahead of time
if Tuesday wasn't about getting
everything lined up to where it needs to
be because rich McKay and the
competition committee didn't properly
anticipate what was gonna happen when
they got to Arizona I think it's part of
the obligation of the gig I know it's
not easy but part of the obligation is
to anticipate what's going to happen
once you get there to the side of the
league meeting so you can properly
support influence whatever the process
to get to the right spot and I don't
like the idea of all this being thrown
together in a day yeah back when I was
practicing law give me let me give this
example if somebody ever had to like
pull an all-nighter and stay at the
office all night like that was kind of a
badge of honor oh I pulled an
all-nighter but the people who God had
said if you had your act together you
wouldn't have to pull the all-nighter
right and chances are when you're
working all night like that you're gonna
make mistakes that you wouldn't have
made if you'd have been doing your work
in a more diligent
fashion no no no doubt about it you're
right it does seem like it almost
catches everybody by surprise we're
there and they're kind of figuring that
on the fly in the hour or two our
meetings that they're all having
together the coaches the owners GM's
everything like that yeah you would
think there would be a little more
conversation leading up to it
to not only just change the rule but
okay we're leaning towards we want to
change the rule and why we're having
this conversation you know a month
before the owners meetings and all that
this is what we like let's start
thinking about some of the issues that
could come about if we do change this
rule so you're further down the
conversation line when all said and done
and you can hash out more problems
instead of yes now then kind of all
figured out before they're all leaving
the hotel or going to play golf or
whatever it may be it does seem like
there's a little bit disconnect there so
that's a good one all right I think my
other one you know it's a grievance just
because I just want to remind everybody
and it's almost like that I want to talk
about like the Pittsburgh Steelers this
is something my MD s Michael David Smith
wrote yesterday about the non pass
Senate and pass interference calls or
pass interference calls that swayed a
game and I just want to remind everybody
again I always believe in this the
football gods football karma right the
New Orleans Saints I know they got
screwed in the NFC Championship game I
really am NOT trying to take anything
away from that I feel for Sean Payton
and Drew Brees and thus and the Saints
fans and all that but I also just want
to remind everybody to you know they
were the benefit of benefit or been a
factor of three beneficiary thank you
very much
third time's always a children know it I
need help after two but either way they
were the beneficiary of three very bad
calls in week 16 against the you know
the Pittsburgh Steelers verse the New
Orleans Saints where Pittsburgh was
controlling the game pittsburgh was
called on pass interference on to fourth
down plays one was in the end zone on
Joe Hayden another one was a defensive
penalty called on the Pittsburgh
Steelers and there was another one for
the game-winning touchdown basically by
the New Orleans Saints that was
offensive pass in there
so you know again I'm just reminding
everybody out there if that played out
the right way and there wasn't and there
was the correct call made I don't know
maybe New Orleans Saints are on the road
in that NFC Championship game in LA and
it's a whole different scenario either
way and Pittsburgh it's probably in the
playoffs oh they have as much to
complain about this you know in a way as
the New Orleans Saints dude that's all
I'm trying to say there yeah I don't
know what you're trying to say my next
grievance is I don't know what you just
said what's your point my point I'm
being sarcastic with your setback but
the bottom line is you don't want games
to be decided by bad calls regardless of
whether you are the beneficiary of that
or the party who gets screwed yeah one
last quick one on the way out the door
quick quick grievance to anyone out
there who is suggesting that our
comments about those who we criticize
reflect an unwillingness by us to accept
criticism we gladly take criticism we
just check out social media check out
the comments at the Pro Football Talk
comm website you can criticize us all
you want as long as the check clears I
don't care what you say and it's part of
that passion that brings you two to
football and brings you to the show
brings you the website in the front
place if you want to criticize this go
ahead and every once in a while we
actually learned something from it no
problem or PFT live coming at you right
after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports